I think this is my first endgame exclam
class that I'm going to be teaching so
we'll see how it goes where I have three
examples prepared for you guys
they're quite difficult most of them so
I'm going to give you some time to try
to solve them once again they're not
going to be easy they're played by very
very powerful players the first example
is a game between Fisher and Petrossian
from way back and this is the position
I'm going to give you a few minutes to
think about what you have to do why to
move I think we're going to be white in
all three examples if we manage to go
through all three but yeah in this
position white to move try to create a
plan understand what you need to do in
the position and avoid all counter play
this is going to be the theme of the day
trying to avoid our opponents counter
play because that's a crucial part of
building your technique in the endgame
it's not allowing your opponent to get
what he wants especially when you have
the advantage because it's very very
easy to spoil endgame advantages if
you're not paying attention to your
opponent's ideas so this is the position
obviously white is better for countless
reasons one of them is that he has the
majority on the Queen side black has a
passed pawn but right now he cannot
really make use of it it's quite a weak
pawn more or less the liability in the
position at the moment and whites pieces
are simply just much more active the
bishop on d3 is attacking this pawn on
a6 which is probably the most important
weakness in blacks position as as we
will see later on the problem is how are
we going to try to take advantage of it
so give it some thought
maybe bounce some ideas off of me if you
have yes
Bishop to f5 okay this is an interesting
move ice but again we were discussing
the a six upon is the weakness right so
why would we take one of the attackers
of that a six pawn and exchange one of
his I mean one of his pieces there that
it's quite passive at the moment
it's not really doing anything the
bishop on e6 I would say is a bad piece
for black hitting hitting the pawn on d5
our Bishop on d3 is actually very very
powerful it's one of our best pieces in
the position opened up it controls both
sides of the board so I don't really see
why we should do this I can play
something like king of faith maybe
defending my rook I mean if you take on
his six then I'm probably going to take
back with the rook and slowly slowly we
were liquidating the pieces and that can
only help black right exactly exactly no
the white bishop to be honest is once
again one of the best pieces of white so
I think Bishop a5 doesn't necessarily
accomplish much Knight to c5 is an
option so we do have we do have
candidate moves Bishop a5 I think we can
eliminate quite quickly 95 for sure is
one of the candidate moves but let's try
to add some more options to the table
and if we cannot find anything but 95
then we're going to go with that one
thank you
Luque to see one absolutely to grab the
empty file but we can do that later we
can do that later
he's not really threatening to take that
file I mean maybe rook c7 but I think we
can work against that quite quite easily
any other candidates night to b6 of
course attacking attacking the rook the
problem with Knight b6 I think I will
just simply play rugby eight and then
you're actually in trouble well not in
trouble because you can go back but
you're losing some some important
temples yeah very good
exactly that's that's probably the best
move in the position before once again
the theme of today's lessons is do not
hurry and do not allow your opponent any
sort of counter play so 95 the problem
with 95 is that I'm simply going to play
a 5 I'm going to get rid of that
weakness and then it's going to be much
more difficult to create a passport if
we play b4 on the other hand first which
is the move Fischer played whenever he
plays a 5 right now we have what move
we have b5 yeah and that's going to be a
passport but more importantly
potentially a protected passport because
then this point from a2 is going to go
to a for defending the pawn on b5 and if
you put upon on a5 that will become most
probably a liability a weakness because
we can transfer the knight Knight c5
Knight b3 let's say the point is on a
for the ponies on b5 and then the pawn
on e5 is going to be a huge weakness
right so on the defending side generally
you're trying to exchange pawns as many
as possible right simplify the position
as much as possible that's why before
avoiding that is is very very good
it's a good move all right before king
of fate night to see five and as we can
see if he goes a five we're going to go
B five and the position is slowly slowly
becoming hopeless almost again I'm going
to go a four-night b3 then I'm going to
put my work on C on the C file and
slowly slowly you're going to run out of
moves also at the right moment I'm going
to play b6 b7 and potentially put my my
pawn on the seventh rank then defended
96 plenty plenty of ideas to convert my
advantage right much better than if the
a the pawns on the a file would be
exchanged so we play the move Bishop to
ca
f 3 very powerful move why is that keeps
the night out keeps the night out from
if from e4 also prepares the coming of
the king in the center king of to King
heat wreaking before if I manage to
bring my king to d4 the position is
going to be extremely extremely
difficult rook a7 rook c5 what are we
preventing with this move once again
we're talking about prevention let's go
back one move what was blacks main idea
again if you push a 5 I'm gonna go B 5
always you could have pushed a 5 before
also putting the rock on a 7 doesn't
necessarily aid in that plan a 5 is
always going to be met with B 5 and
that's going to be all she wrote
mm-hmm that's definitely enough to win
if I managed to create a passport then
it's going to be very difficult to
defend it's already very difficult to
defend
absolutely
black threatened the position was Knight
to d7 simple as that trying to exchange
one of his powerful one of whites most
powerful pieces the knight on c5
exchange some pieces and rookie 5 plays
exactly against that because the night
is going to be mobile so Rocky 5 was
played Bishop to d7 all right and this
is one of the critical moments in the
game let's try to understand the
position and once again come up with a
set of candidate moves a4 is one of them
sure
to keep the bishop out from b5 right I
think actually as as mr. Karen Weston is
mentioning Bishop b5 is a threat
exchanging some pieces you definitely
don't want to play after Bishop e5
Bishop takes b5 because that would
basically open up the a file and allow
blacks rooks to get active which is
definitely not something that we would
like as well anything else besides a4
which is a very sensible sensible move
okay
yes a classic this is a classic so yeah
that's that that's another sensible idea
I can tell you that the move that was
played in the game is actually not
something that the engines like
initially but as you go as you go along
with with the variation with the game
they start to understand the position a
little bit better and give credit to the
wise decision yeah broken anyone no
absolutely at at at some point is going
to be carefully improved by white but
also let's ask ourselves
besides Bishop b5 so let's go let's say
we go
a4 YUM what would black do in the
position to try to create some sort of
counter play or try to make use of his
plan what is his plan mmm
yes Bishop d7 was his last ball so he
played Bishop d7 let's say you were
going to play for to avoid Bishop b5 but
now maybe he has an extra option
let's see a rock to be a night xa6
I think and the poornam before he's
protected the night on Essex then I go
b5 this is game over right so Rocky 8 is
not working his position is more or less
paralyzed but he does have one little
option of trying to avoid his final fate
d4 let's see d4
I'm gonna try to just simply improve my
position and potentially target that
horn so I'm the consequence of you
playing d4 is that now the C 4 square is
available for my rook so I think I'm
going to go rook c1 rook c4 and then
oops
the d4 pawn is going to be lost
it seems so before whenever you are
advancing that that that free pawn on on
the D file you have to be very careful
because it's no longer going to be
protected and it's going to become a
clear target
with the idea Bishop c6 with the idea
okay yes protecting the pawn but most
importantly voila yeah
Bishop c6 and 97 and trying to exchange
the night yeah if we manage to do that
we might have some chances of survival
of course it's not going to be trivial
still white is way on top but definitely
is going to become slowly slowly a
little bit easier for black to deal with
his problems for example if after let's
say Bishop c6 we go rook c1 I think
after 97 okay we take take and the
problem is that we cannot take on d5
right now because we should take say for
that pawn is hanging right now if you
don't play a rook c1 and maintain
control over the a4 pawn then after
ninety seven ninety xd7 I'm going to
take with the rook because my bishop on
c6 is not going to be attacked so I have
options
yeah so in this in this position instead
of a for maybe something uh something
else
Arjen yes
we yes absolutely that's that's
definitely a candidate move but can you
explain a little bit why you would give
your strong night from c5 for his
passive let's say bishop on d7 mm-hmm
it does prevent a lot of counter play
and then after that we're going to have
the the endgame of two rooks and Bishop
versus two rooks and night which
cooperation is better between the bishop
and the rook or the rook and a knight
nope nope rook and Bishop is well of
course there is always exceptions but
yeah rook and Bishop is generally
considered to be stronger than the rock
and the night especially with pawns on
both sides of the board especially with
a symmetrical structures Knight and
queen is usually better than Knight and
Bishop because yeah the rook and and and
the bishop complement each other very
very well the Queen and the knight
complement each other very well very
well
so yes Knight xd7 is not looking very
good at first glance because you're
giving such a strong piece from c5 the
problem is you're going to get a very
very nice advantage afterwards Rock
Texas 7 continue absolutely natural play
is usually the best course of action and
that is rook to Roxy one of course look
to c1 is the move
you're also threatening was the same
problems are still there for black
whenever he goes a5 we go b5 would pass
and then we have a passport protected
potentially protected passed pawn
because once again
a4 we protect that point and we don't
even have to hurry and another trump of
exchanging immediately is that we once
again take control over the c5
and we're attack we're preparing what
move yeah we're threatening let's say
what move rock sistex exactly we're
threatening the penetration on the sixth
rank and that would be almost game over
so ruby six had to be played rook c7
Knight to d7 rocky to g6 is he
threatening anything
no he's not reading anything so what do
we do when our opponent doesn't
necessarily have any threats do we hurry
or do we just slowly improve our
position slowly improve our position so
what is something that could improve our
position at this moment yes a forest is
one way yeah anything else a4 can wait
right also there's something more
important double the rooks can can wait
as well
let's bring the king
let's bring the King to the center if we
manage to I mean if we manage to get the
King to d4 the game is just simply over
we're going to attack the other weakness
the pawn on d5 with the King on d4 King
ready to jump in play whenever we
exchange potentially the rooks so if we
manage to get the king to d4 it's just
going to be all she wrote
so king of two was what Fischer played
h5
oh yes we probably could have played
King III he chose to completely
eliminate any any sort of counter play
he played a move f4 to take away the e5
square so if King III maybe Knight e5
would have came on the board and then
the bishop doesn't really have work to
go because if you go to c2 then I just
simply go Knight c4 and then I I'm
starting to get some some sort of
counter play you you feel like you're
you're at least one of your pieces
getting a little bit more active yeah so
yeah I mean that's whenever one of my
pieces gets active in a completely
hopeless position it feels so good you
know it feels so you know you're losing
most probably Eve even so but you feel
so good to just have some sort of play
and not feel like you're just waiting to
be slaughtered so you should try to
maintain that feeling for your opponent
so he played that for h4
absolutely you can
or you can provoke another weakness was
the consequence of the move age for
go along the line it weakens the pawn on
it on h4 so we can play what move first
King f3 exactly which forces f5
exactly and now this is another weakness
obviously right the seventh rank has has
become a little bit more weaker you no
longer have the option of potentially
playing f6 and controlling the e5 square
so that's a problem as well your pawns
are on light squares that could become a
problem as well
you're you're full of problems so King
III just continue continue the normal
natural play d4 King the tube
what is now White's plan
easy very easy plan actually to paralyze
his position even more how exactly bring
the bishop to see for the night cannot
move because ron capps seven will come
on the board and then some nasty
discovery attacks and then King goes to
d3 keeping control over d4 square and
that's going to be very very quickly
game over okay you're going to run out
of moves basically so you play the move
Knight to b6
rook e7 this doesn't look very good
Lister this doesn't look very good
95 okay
go long rook f7 King yay look to be 7
tonight takes d4
hmm he played a move Bishop c4 and
actually the game ended here because of
96 what what could I do
let's find tell me the whole variation
correct very good correct game over
right and he just played before at the
beginning after that he hasn't moved his
his pawns on the queenside he played
everything and he improved his his whole
position through his pieces through the
maneuvers of the King King f3 weakening
the seventh rank and so on
he just slowly slowly forced his
opponent to make one more weakness every
single move one more weakness and so on
yeah so quite an instructive and game
Fisher versus Petrosian from Buenos
Aires as you mentioned I think it was a
candidate candidate match in 1971 Fisher
versus Petrosian this one I would say is
a little bit more difficult
let's take some time because there are
some maneuvering going on and we have to
understand it this is a game I think
both unique the pre-strung and the vs.
11 fish who was also a strong
Grandmaster in 1937 very old games
I will pick more modern games for next
time all games are good of course of
course especially if they're instructive
yeah so this is it
let's try to understand the position
material is equal you do have double
points on the a file you do have a
potentially weak pawn on e5
but you have a very nice idea available
if you wouldn't have it then black would
be perfectly fine let's try to find that
an idea and we're going to find it by
asking ourselves what does black want to
do which is quite easy the antidote is
up he cannot push the c1 know that that
night is a great blocker yeah yeah block
hearing piece
absolutely I mean black is just trying
to activate his his King yeah if he
manages to get to e6 force the rook out
of the way then somehow put his knight
bring his knight into play maybe
something like I don't know 97 96 or 97
Knight B 5 and so on if Y doesn't do
anything you're you're the one who's
going to have weaknesses one weakness on
e5 the two the two points on the a file
double pawns and then if the knight
moves from c4 you're going to have
problems defending against the expansion
of the C pawn the advancement of the C
pawn I see you Arjun I see and now we
know the plan yeah we know blacks plan
so we have to eliminate that the counter
play if you go rogue d8 I'm gonna go
King g7 he's right king is 7 yeah I mean
you go you can go something like maybe
you're okay yeah but then I go tonight
c7 I think and then I mean if you get
your rook on a 7 despite the fact that
it attacks the pawn on e6 that one that
weakness is clearly defended and right
now I have King the 5 coming I think
you're actually in trouble
exactly exactly so the rook is not
really doing anything there
unfortunately
let's try to calculate of course that
that's the first same thing yeah rook d7
should be the first nice thing because
it just blocks him from coming to East 7
what is black going to do after up d7
rook d7 90 d7 and then I mean I'm going
to start bringing my king up out king of
to Luke a seven
you said King g8 here
that's unpleasant yeah so actually after
okay seven maybe you can try to play 96
first then 97 I think so 96
wait route d7 was a bit hasty I think
Luka a seven-story was a bit hasty what
if I go 96 directly here
hmm you're losing up seven so I think
you do have some counterplay of course
after c4 there should be some sort of
counter play I'm not sure if it's enough
because I'm forcing your king back to g8
and now I'm going to have a lot of
mating ideas make it mating threats so I
can just simply play something like
maybe Ruby seven right Rugby seven I
don't think you can push the pawn
because of Ruby eight now you're forced
to go here actually you can still do
that
and now mmm
it's a good question
I have ways to stop the pond I'm not I'm
just not sure if it's enough so let's
say go I take here then I check you
again then I have rook F seven and then
rook F one but I'm not sure that's not I
want something more than that yeah I
don't think I have something more so I
am probably going to have to play rook F
seven which is not enough let's try to
find something better
that's an interesting plan Knight to g7
let's start from here
96 fields right it just feels like the
right move c4 cap 7 King g8 I can I can
that's that's probably the better
alternative just to go rogue have to
yeah cuz that pawn is running really
fast that phone is running really really
fast and now I think I'm going to be
able to block the pond if you go c3 rook
rook c2 and then I'm going to bring my
knight back Knight to e4 going to take
the pawn on c3 and most probably I'm
going to end up one point out something
like that 96 might ah
94 that's the problem
very tricky very tricky and games are
extremely extremely tricky
let's see
he's threatening to play route 86
absolutely
only if I have the King on f2 already
only only if I go king of 2d6
then I think Group g7 should be okay
because I catch your pawn right yeah
yeah so but the problem is after a king
after I just simply go c3 and you no
longer catch that part we found the
refutation guys maybe correct correct
maybe that was a bit too hasty yeah I
agree I agree maybe just bring the king
of no let's try to bring the king even
though I'd really wanted to make that
work but yeah it's probably too much
so now our June 95 or 96 okay let's go
with Knight a5 first night of my top
five years topping 96 I'm just going to
bring my king
actually now that you went you went this
way I can go okay seven and not worry
about you bringing 96-97
hmm yeah I think night of five is just
not the best route for the night I think
maybe 96 because anyway you kind of want
to go to d4 maybe yeah that's kind of
the big square for you but also with
with the night only six you have the
option of jumping to c7 bit more
defensive but you want to evict this
roof from the seventh rack
yeah if you can
wait but you're not really threatening
97 right now because I will have 96 damn
do I have 96 now my King is a bit closer
that's the difference my King is a bit
closer do you want to play c4 here all
right so let's go like this all right
now you're still threatening but now
okay maybe I will go like this I will
allow you to push your cone all the way
to the no but that's bad and this is
just game over this is just came
overnight b3 is coming so 96 is really
really dangerous I should keep the my
knight there
okay
continue
yeah I shouldn't complicate with 96
simple place should be should be enough
King e8 let's go here
ninety-seven now
Knight c7 I had a crazy idea but it's
not working
what I was thinking was rugby six King
the seven I think it's the only move if
you take I take with the pawn and then
my pawn is just way too fast and now I
want to play e6 and then if you take
with anything but the rook I have 95
check but unfortunately you would take
with the rook and that's a check if I
would have the King on d3 that would
work some ah no okay let's go King III
let's continue with King III King e8
rugby 797 and now I'm just going to play
normal normal move
or I have an even better idea King here
I actually want to bring my king to see
for if I would have another move I'll
plane 96 King move somewhere and then
I'm playing King c4 and I want to block
that C pawn with the King probably
probably the best move
well my b6 does work I think let's try
Knight b6 King here and now I want to go
here King c4
I think if king e5 I might have check
this should be winning for me I think I
think you still have some way I know you
don't actually you do have 98 I think 98
and if you take my d6 we recap 7 recap 6
so in this position if you if you don't
take the rook you take here I think I
have recap 6 but even this should be
winning 4 oh yeah yeah this is
completely winning 4 wipe my pawn is way
too fast
I play Knight c7 next the pawn rolls so
I think I think this is the plan
just bring in the King to c4 slowly
slowly not allowing obviously not
allowing now king c8 that would force
our look of the seventh rank and then
just 96 Kings before and most of his
pieces are more or less paralyzed right
now that a 6 pawn is is going to be a
weakness so Nigel 7 I think would have
been a good try nonetheless about what
to do after rock c7 as black after rook
d7 Lukas e7 that should be the main
question
that's the first thing we should
calculate because it's just the most
forced variation Luke c7 trying to get
the rock off the seven rack and trying
to accomplish his plan along the way of
bringing the King to the center as soon
as possible so what to do now Knight b6
it's an interesting move
c4 Luke takes c7 and then Knight takes
e4 but even then my king is very closed
and and the knight on c7 is quite
powerful because it defends the a6 pawn
so let's see
Knight BC no I don't want to take okay
c4 let's go let's see like let's see
this variation because I have a feel I
have whoa what is this
all right correct
now King e7
the king might be a bit too slow yeah
and despite the fact you're a pawn up I
think this should be okay for black I
think he has more than enough
comfortably yeah because you cannot
really get to the a six point very
easily so I can play something like
might be five maybe
and then 94-96 reroute my knight take
this point or this pawn and actually I
think black shouldn't have any problems
here we got the pawn but it's not enough
he exchanged the rooks he got his King
into play let's try to keep him passive
it's important to keep him passive
white found a very nice maneuver play
them over old d8 came to e7
and now rug d6 because it takes it takes
d6 after Knight takes c6 is a fork right
so it all started from the beginning he
forced the rope to go to c7 so that it's
on it's on the danger square rook c7
rook da you're forced to play King is 7
because 96 is a trap and after root d6
York becomes passive York has to go on
the h7 square and my position is going
to be dominant so look to a7 if you try
to go route d7 for active play you're
probably not going to succeed because
the night goes to support the to support
the pon da pawn let's say c4 Rock a8
rook c8 and slowly slowly we're going to
take all the points and simply have a
winning position yeah I think it's 2
points up this should be definitely
winning with slow play of course it's
going to take a little bit of technique
to convert it but still that should be
winning you're not getting enough
counter play with that point so he
decided to go for passive defense root 2
a7 what to do now
where do we go in the rook we have to we
have to stay on the six rank Roxy six or
ruby six roxy six absolutely but the
question is why
what if it goes what would be the
difference if you go rook to be six sure
but you're not you don't necessarily
want to take that sapone to be honest
imagine this
okay you go Roxy six rotates c5 yeah you
make two moves in a row
somehow I go Roxy seven I force the rook
exchange I'm fine with you being a pawn
up your pawn up is is a double point on
the a5 but my king is closer to the
center right so what what you actually
want to do your plan is to bring the
King first king of two King III King e4
and then you can do whatever you want
then you can start collecting pawns but
what you want to do is dominate black
yeah do not allow him any counter play
even even if that comes at the cost of
not taking material yeah do not hurry we
taking material it's a different problem
actually the the the mover of b6 allows
the move f6 and that creates once again
some sort of imbalance in the position
some sort of counter play
Roxy six dozen because Roxy six now if
you go f6 I take and then I take on c5
and then you don't have the move rook
csepp and I'm just going to be a pawn up
after king d7 now look to b6 I'm not
going to take your c5 pawn and now f6 is
not the possibility anymore right King
g7 he won back
and now we gain a temple at least we
gained a temple King 2 F 2 F 6 was
played King to ito rook to a8 rook to c6
now we're going to the c5 pawn because
he doesn't have Roxy 7 and our King is
very close to the centre f65 room takes
d5 Knight d6 what to do
rook takes pawn check King f6
mm-hmm but then I'm not so sure how this
position is do I have to wait oops no
another yeah this might be enough as
well oh wait can I go look c8 No
I was trying to play something like
rocky 8 and then rocky 5 the problem is
you have rookies oxy 6 it's kind of
annoying so this might be winning as
well this might might be winning as well
he chose a different different path and
that was route to c7 king g6
Knight x d6 king tasty six rock kh7
basically you're going to be able to
create a passport far away yeah
the e5 pawn doesn't matter that much
what matters the most is that you're
going to be able to have a passport very
very far away from the center of the
action on the H file the second weakness
exactly exactly and once again his point
in the center is not that valuable it's
very well controlled by the key yeah
technical window rook to b8 v g7 wrote
to be to King to f1 came to have three
running into e4 I think and you have
some problems so no counter play
whatsoever rook takes g6 King to e5
let's grab another pawn absolutely
greediness is good sometimes King to f4
a six
look to a-1 king - 8 e - r ok - King D 1
rule takes 8 3 and now H for absolutely
the king is blocked on the e-file yeah
because if he goes on the F file you go
rook F 8 promote and so on route d3 rook
d7 - which one he pushed the Jeep
the point is whenever you go Roop
whenever you go kinky - I'm going to do
what most probably Roque going to force
the exchange of the a pond with the a
pond that's eliminating all the
counterplay you have in the position
game over yeah and the king is cut like
for example if you go King here the King
is cut on the third-ranked so rook here
is forced say here now if I if I go King
g3 well what is the white going to do
of course g5 or not H 5 H 5 would
probably be a huge mistake because after
King age 4 this might actually this is a
draw King goes to g5 and I think with a
with a king in between your pawns this
is impossible to win but g5 just wins on
the spot yeah so let's go back to the
game because there were some more moves
instead of King he - he played Rock d7
King c5 and he resigned so yeah that's
big part of improving your technique and
that is not hurrying and always trying
to spot any single gram of counter play
of your opponents and enemy he lay that
try to stop it at all costs
you
[Music]